hi
uh welcome to uh
the first
computer musing of the uh
is it echo is it okay um
uh okay there's a welcome to the first
computer musing this uh this quarter i
expect to have another one uh on 13th of
december
uh i'm sorry i i can't do it during
finals week so this is the monday after
finals week and so i know a lot of
you'll be gone home if so you can watch
it on tv
uh these uh
the stanford
scpd whatever it stands for
has been uh
very good about
putting the back
lectures in this series online and uh
i i've watched most of them again and i
realized that i had
now i had better stop telling the same
jokes all the time
and
and i have to pay more attention to
other little mannerisms that i'll try to
get rid of but anyway uh uh it is
possible uh
uh
let's hope to uh to watch uh
this again uh
later on uh in case you wanna see you
know why i made certain mistakes or
whatever it is and also
we hope this will be a resource for
future uh people who
who are
interested in in the cool stuff that i
that i might have uh
uh
well
the the point of these lectures is that
is uh whenever i whenever i hear
something that i think is pretty
interesting that i that i don't think is
in any of our other curriculum
i can't resist coming in from i'm not
always i'm telling somebody about and
today is a special
is a special case
my title today is hooray for probability
theory and really that's a sentiment i
felt very strongly twice this year
i went when i had been working hard on a
problem for a long time uh
well for me a long time is two weeks but
anyway i've been working very hard on
these problems and i decided to give up
on it and then um
all of a sudden uh
i
um wake up in the morning say wait
probability theory might help and then i
find not only a way to solve the problem
but a way that's that's uh easy and
beautiful and so on
uh i hope you i hope you agree when you
see that when you see the two things i'm
going to talk about in fact the first
one i'm going to talk about
is is something i learned about just at
the end of june
and
it's so uh it's so simple so useful
so beautiful that i think it should be
in all books on mathematics but i had
never heard about it until last june and
i you know i thought you know by the
time you get to be as old as me you
can it's not very often that you hear
something that's that has all those
characteristics anymore because most of
the simple stuff uh uh presumably has
has been well hashed over and maybe a
lot of you will know this it's just it
was just me that didn't know it but
anyway it's a it if i were
you know if i had known about it or
before i retired i certainly would have
put it in
in my book concrete mathematics and now
um
uh i i was able to sneak it in as
exercise number 62 in art of computer
programming but
uh i want to i'm glad to see so many
people here today so that uh you can
pass the word on because it's it like
it's really
a beautiful result now how can anything
possibly live up to so much hype uh well
we'll have to see so so first so i i
guess i better
just write down a theorem and see uh and
and then we'll add to the theorem but uh
the first uh
result um
uh comes out with uh about probability
theory and uh
uh so let's
uh well i won't write down a few and
that's a boring way to
let let's suppose that i have n coins
and i'm gonna flip uh
each coin and i want to see how what
it's the odds that i or the probability
that i get uh heads
uh
k times so
uh i've got coins and the coins are each
each are biased in a certain way so
let's say that p
one
um or you know p sub
sub j is that is the
probability
that
coin
j
comes up heads
and then q j is the opposite um
that that it doesn't come up heads uh it
comes up tails and uh
uh
for the sake of uh
um
to be definite i'm going to assume that
the coin does not come up on its rim so
that people
p j plus q j equals one
uh now
um has anybody heard this problem before
probably okay
uh furthermore uh
now we want to know uh so
so we can form
uh
the
generating function the polynomial q one
plus p one z
q two plus p two z
uh and so on all the way up to qn plus
pnz
and
this will be
some polynomial a0 plus a1 z plus
um a
nz to the n
and a sub k
will be what that'll be the probability
um
that um
k
times
our k heads
we're obtained during these these
classes okay each
each call each toss is independent of
the others and so uh
i um
this is a very elementary thing in
probability theory i don't think i'm
gonna have to explain that to the
distinguished audience here today so but
we get these numbers the a one through a
n
and um
uh
and they are non-negative number
and each one does somebody want to say
something
okay so now the
um
the theorem
okay now the the the mean
the the the average number of heads
is uh is these is obvious and two and
that's the sum of all the probabilities
because we've got
chance p1 that we're going to get ahead
on the first and p2 on the second and we
add these all up and this is the average
so this is the this is the mean or the
average expected number whatever you
want to call it
um and so here's my
theorem
um
it says that if k
is less than or equal to mu
then
a k minus 1 is strictly less than a
k so
for for example suppose that i've got
you know 100 coins here
and that and maybe the
um maybe this mu is
like 31.6
um
so i'm saying that
that uh if
if you're less than the average
or equal to the average um
then uh you know so so
your chance of getting 27 coins is
bigger than the chance of getting 26.
the chance of between 28 is bigger than
27.
30 is bigger than
than 31.
um
now
also
uh if k is
greater than or equal to mu
then
a k plus 1
is less than a k
it says that after
you after you pass the average uh it's
going to go down
your chances are going down now that's
uh the second statement is actually
equivalent to the first
uh because if you change
heads to tails
you are just changing all the cues to
peas
and excuse me sean i
i keep hearing myself sort of uh
with a buzz is that uh
is that a problem
it's okay now yeah okay so
changing uh heads to tails uh just
reverses all the
all the coefficients a n becomes a zero
a n minus one becomes a one and so on so
so anything that goes and and mu changes
to n minus mu
uh so uh anything that that happens at
the beginning of the sequence
uh is gonna you know the same thing is
going to occur on the other side but
anyway this is a
uh uh a result that's sort of
intuitively obvious but um
uh i
you know i had never i never heard it i
i knew it in special cases but i never
had heard it before and and this has
many corollaries that i'm going to get
to later so so before i go to the
corollaries and applications let's try
to prove this result because the proof
is also very nice
um
so
uh is it clear what i'm trying to prove
though first of all that if you're
flipping coins and
you want to know what's the odds of
getting uh
getting k heads and k is less than or
equal to the average
then that's bigger than your chance of
getting less than uh
k minus one heads
uh strictly bigger
uh
and um
let's see this is
weird let me see is this
let me just check that it's correct
when when all the p's are one and when
q's are zero
um because that because i'm a little
worried there if all the p's are one
that means i'm always going to get n
heads right so a n is one
and all these others a's are zero here
and so uh i have better i
what yeah but it's it's strictly
okay uh
or a k equals zero or
or or they're both zero
or both are zero um
uh
so so there isn't there's this little
exception
that's one of the great advantages you
have when you
when you give a lecture you always think
of something that you don't think of
when you're writing the book okay
okay so uh
but it's going to be strict it's going
to be strictly less than uh in in the
interesting cases and i and and i'm
going to want to i'm not going to want
to know
um
so trivially
we can have some zeros at the very at
the beginning
or at the end i mean all the
p's could be zero as well um
so we got this same caveat
both zero okay now um but let's let's
consider first the case when all the all
the probabilities are equal so
so first case one
is uh p sub j equals p
for all j
all right well that's easy
what's this polynomial in that case so
that's q plus p pz
raised to the nth power
and we know the binomial theorem so
that is the summation of you know
n
choose k
p
to the k
z to the k
q to the n minus k
oh which is you know the coefficient so
a sub k is the coefficient of z to the k
which is
n choose k p to the k q the n minus k
i'll write i'll write that as n
factorial over k factorial n minus k
factorial
and p to the k
q to the n minus k
now uh so let's check it let's let's
check if our result works
what is mu
mu is equal to n times p
the average
uh and ak minus 1
divided by ak
we just plug in
so
i got n
n factorial k minus 1 factorial
n minus k plus 1 factorial
um
p to the k minus 1.
q to the n minus
sorry q to the n minus
k plus 1. and then i've got to divide
but like a k which is n factorial k
factorial minus k factorial p to the k q
to the n minus k a lot of cancellation
occurring here so the the p to the k
goes out with this p to the k the
q to the n minus k goes out with this q
to the n minus k
uh the n factorials go
away uh the k factorial
almost cancels with k minus 1 factorial
and n minus k plus 1 factorial almost
cancels with this guy so what so i'm
left with p i'm sorry q
over p
k
over n
plus 1 minus k
and
now i want to show that that if k is
less than
um or equal to mu
that this is less than
one
strictly less than one so so uh
the
thing is if k
if k is
is less than or equal mu
then
uh
k over mu
is uh less than or equal to n n plus one
minus k over n plus one minus mu
this is true if i put any number in
place there because you know you
multiply it out what do you get
uh
k times n plus one
minus k mu
multiply this by this and and that is
supposed to be less than or equal to mu
times
n plus 1 minus k mu
and that certainly
is is true
n plus 1 being
positive so so here's uh
something that i can use also what about
q over p
oh well q is
is n
minus
np
uh
i'm sorry yeah q is
is um
q over p is 1 minus p over
p which is n minus mu
over
n minus
mu over mu
because you multiply both the numerator
and denominator
by n and you get this
so
so then my
of
in in my proof then i have a
k minus 1 over a k is equal to q over p
times k over n minus 1 minus k
um and this is equal to n minus mu over
mu
and k over n minus 1 minus k well that's
let me just make that less than or equal
because k over n minus 1 minus k is less
than or equal to mu over n plus 1 minus
mu right so this is equal to n minus mu
over n plus 1 minus mu
and it is definitely less than one that
was what we wanted to prove strictly
less than one so a k minus one is less
than a sub k
uh unless they're both zero
uh which could happen if p is equal to
one as we observed before
now
so we proved this result in the case
where all the probabilities are the same
and now
we want to prove it the other case where
the probabilities are not the same
well
uh so now let's suppose that
that
i've got two probabilities p1 and p2
that are
different and also different from zero
or one zero and one are
trivial cases that
there's no
there's no chance when p when when the
probability is zero or one so suppose we
have this condition
then uh we consider
uh another set of probabilities so i'll
take p1 prime
to be p
p1
minus
epsilon
and p2 prime to be p2
plus epsilon
and uh then of course q1 prime is going
to be q1 plus epsilon and q2 prime is q2
minus epsilon
but i i subtracted epsilon is some
terribly small number i subtracted
epsilon from for uh
in one case and added the other case
because i still have the same mu mu
prime is is p1 prime plus pn prime
is the same as p1
through pn so i haven't changed the
average i'm just changing that making
this uh first coin a little less
tiny bit less probable the second coin
tiny bit more probable
now
so let's compare
you know what the different coefficients
are and let's figure out what's a k
prime
and
ak prime
uh
is equal to a k
now here we have well we can work it out
um
and uh uh
it's tedious to go through the details
but i'll show you how it starts
so
i'll come back to this in a minute uh
let's start out and figure out what
we've done so q1 prime plus p1 prime z
times q2 prime plus p2 prime z
is equal to
q1
um plus epsilon
plus p1 prime
uh let's
simplify a little bit q1
plus p1 z
plus epsilon times one minus z
and
then the second term is
same same deal q2 plus p2 z but now
minus epsilon times one minus e
and so this turns out to be equal to
what we had before q1 plus p1z
of q2 plus p2 z
and then it um
i actually want to work out the other
term exactly and i but but i won't bore
you with it you have to trust me it
turns out to be epsilon times p1 minus
p2 minus epsilon
times one minus z squared
and uh you could you can check that out
with any your favorite computer algebra
system
uh so
but
it's nice because it
factors in this way
and therefore i claim that a
k prime is equal to a k
plus
epsilon
times p1 minus p2
minus epsilon
times some factor alpha k
where
where alpha k comes from i mean here you
see
you multiply
you you multiply this by all the other
guys uh q3 plus p3 z and all the other
and all the others and so so the same
thing occurs here
p3z and all the other
um and and
on the last term too
um and so
what's the perturbation in these
coefficients it's something that's
epsilon times p1 minus p2 minus epsilon
times something that has nothing to do
with p1 and p2
so so this is alpha k is some function
of
p3
uh to pn
but p1 and p2
don't appear there so so
um
uh
now
the point is
um i'm going to try to find
uh well the difference between alpha k
prime prime and alpha k minus 1 prime
i'm going to try to make this
extreme i'm going to try to make this
let's say
as
as small as possible
because if i make it as small as
possible and still is positive
uh then it then a you know
that's what i want to prove
if if my result is wrong uh
this is going to have to go negative so
anyway i'm going to look for the for the
i mean i'm going to consider all choices
of all my probabilities
in such a way that this number comes out
to be as small as it is and i'm going to
show that that's still positive
and so uh
what is it it's equal to
uh ak minus ak minus 1 plus epsilon
times p1
minus p2 minus epsilon times sum you
know beta k the
difference of of alpha k
of k minus 1. so um now
if
beta k is not zero
then i can't possibly have have found
the the worst case of these
probabilities
because
i uh because if beta k is not zero
uh you know i can choose epsilon to be
some small number and this is going to
be
smaller
than this guy i mean depends if beta k
is positive
uh you know p1 is
less than p2 so this guy is definitely
negative
uh so i choose you know if vk is
positive then i could choose you know
epsilon to be positive for some positive
small number if vk is negative i can
choose f1 to be some negative number but
certainly
if bk is not equal to zero i'm not at
you know i'm i'm not at the at an
extreme point
uh but on the other hand if bk
beta k is 0
then
i
then i can then i can choose
epsilon
so that
either
p one prime equals zero or
p two prime equals one
because you see how i chose
you see how uh you know so
uh if i can choose epsilon to be uh
p1
unless that makes p2 get too big
uh in which case i choose epsilon so
that p2 gets equal along
so so in other words i uh
so that so if b k is there if beta k is
zero
and then there's also an extreme point
in which uh
in which uh i have a you know an another
zero or another one
so i keep doing this
and and finally i get to the situation
where i can't do it anymore
and that means
that i have
some probabilities are zero some
probabilities are one and all the rest
are equal
with me
there's there's got to be an extreme
point in which all the probabilities
are
one of these three values 0 1 or p
some common value p
all right
now but
but
that's the case i already proved it
correct for
so this is the this is the completion of
the of the proof
because if all the values are zero
uh or 1 or p
you know
that means that i had a
polynomial where
uh well the zeros and ones are really
easy you know they're just little
factors of
uh that don't affect the final
coefficient and they affect mu in the in
the obvious way so uh
any questions on this
i i proved that i proved the amazing
theorem that you that you your chances
of getting
more heads always increase as you get
closer and closer to the mean now you
might say okay so
what what does that mean to me
and
the next uh
result will explain one of the reasons
why
i like it and
so for this let me show you one of the
a page from volume one of the art of
computer programming let's see if we can
zoom up on that how close can you get in
on that uh sean
very good yeah this is page 99
and i'm analyzing one of the
this
the first
algorithm where i really uh
i
thought it was simple and and worth a
you know a non-trivial analysis and that
was to
a problem of finding the maximum of set
of n numbers
and uh it turns out that uh the the
algorithm we all
that we all almost always use is we say
well we compare the first number to the
second number and then um
half the time we might have to switch
but we always compare our current
maximum to the then to the third number
and and uh maybe switch
if necessary and then compare that to
the fourth number and so on and uh
uh at the end uh we want to know maybe
how many times we had to switch during
this algorithm
um and
the it's like flipping a coin because
when you compare the first number to the
second number
half the time you're going to have to
switch
after you compare the max of those two
to the third number one third of the
time you're going to have to switch
and so uh
you get a a histogram like this where
saying you know
certain
certain uh
odds that you never have to switch the
first guy was already the biggest
this is the case where there are 12
you're trying to find a maximum of 12
guys uh the secondly uh though maybe had
to switch once or twice or something
like it looks like you know it peaks
here at two
so uh in fact now we know that in that
uh this
any histogram for a sequence of coin
flips is going to look
it's going to go up and then it's going
to come down and furthermore we know
uh
that the place is going to
where it's going to change from up to
down
is is there at
at mu in fact you see what what we've
shown is that
the maximum
of a1
or a0 through a n
is either
equal to a sub
floor of mu
or
a sub ceiling of mu
if u is an integer we know that the
maximum occurs right at that integer
point but if if if mu
is uh 3.1 then it's either then the
maximum is either going to be
uh a3 or a4
um
and uh
now
i also worked out a formula here for the
for what those
what those probabilities are and in that
particular case of the finding the
maximum problem uh well as they say it's
a coin flip and you can write and you
can write the thing is it like this z
plus one z plus two up to z plus n
and then um
i'm sorry uh
uh let's go
z
z plus 1
up to z plus n minus 1
divided by n factorial
and the coefficient of z to the k will
be the probability that
we needed to to switch our maximum k
times
um
it's it's the same as writing z
times
z
over two plus sorry one half plus
ah z over two
and then two thirds plus z over three
up to n minus one
over n plus z over n
uh
so so so you know that when we make the
last comparison we have a
a chance one over n of of having to
switch um so now uh
so this was the generating function for
how many
uh
how many times i'm going to have to
switch when finding the maximum uh and
the coefficients here
are
are well known as the the sterling
numbers of the coefficient ak in that
case is the is the sterling number
n
uh over k with brackets around it uh
divided by n factorial um and these
numbers uh this uh n um
over k with brackets are
are well known to be also the number of
permutations on n elements that have
exactly k
cycles uh so these numbers are
occur all over the place in in
mathematics um
and uh so now uh
so we have us
and what's mu mu is is equal to one plus
one half
plus up to one over n or the end
harmonic number
uh so so it says that if
if
k is less than
the nth harmonic number which is very
close to the natural log of n
plus euler's constant
so
if k is less than that then the sterling
numbers are getting bigger and if k is
bigger than that sterling numbers are
getting smaller
all right um
now
um in fact i
uh
when i wrote volume 1 i could only
calculate up to n equals 11.
um
i think i might be off by one here 83
plus one or something but
i i took the case of of n equals 12 but
but now it's real easy for me to go to
my computer and calculate all these
sterling numbers for n equals 100 so i
you know so let me show you the same
thing for n equals 100. so if
these are the sterling numbers of
the sterling cycle numbers when you have
100 elements so how many permutations
100 elements have
you know one cycle two cycles etcetera
um
and uh
and the the natural log of 100 is twice
the natural log of 10 so it's about 4.6
or something like that and
at euler's constant you see that
you see why there's a big peak there
but we can
we can go a lot a lot further uh because
we could also say well what about if we
if we bias these things in
a strange way
for example
uh we
we replace z
so we have any any function f of z is a
zero plus a one z
uh a n z to the n
um
now let's let's replace z by c times z
for some constant c
so a zero plus a one c
the
a n
c to the n z to the n
now
if we
if if we now normalize by dividing by f
of c
so we have f of c z over f of c
uh we get uh
you know
v one b zero up to b
and z to the n where now these represent
probabilities again
um because
uh
i could i could refactor so
so where i had before i had q j plus p j
z for a certain coin but now
i've got a c in here so i divide by q j
plus p j c
and again this corresponds to
some other probabilities q j prime plus
p j prime z
the the only point is that the sum of
these two coefficients has to be equal
to one
and so if i
if you know divide by f of c
i can convert many different problems
into
into the same problem about coin tossing
so if you have any polynomial whatsoever
that factors into
uh
linear terms
and the linear terms have have have
non-negative coefficients you know
no no minus signs in here
then that same result is going to have
it is going to hold true so so that the
the the uh the coefficients are going to
get bigger and then they're going to get
smaller and the place where the peak
occurs is going to be
at the
at what we call mu now
what is this mu
uh it's equal to
uh
we can find it by calculating the
average of this which means that we that
we that we differentiate with respect to
z so f prime
uh you take the derivative with respect
to z we get c times f prime of
c z
over f of c
is equal to b zero plus um
i'm sorry it's equal to b one
plus uh two b two
uh
z
uh plus n
b n z to the n minus one that's the
derivative
and then uh if we set z equal to one
we get the average
and so mu in this case mu sub c
is equal to c times f prime c
over f of
c
f was this
this given polynomial and um if we
if we now
uh
say well what if i'm not interested in
sterling numbers n k but instead i'll
multiply by 2 to the k
then i'm skewing the distribution making
the making the
the right hand security numbers you know
more and more important get you know
giving them
the next one twice one significance four
times and so on and so the mean is
moving to the right
and how far is it how far is it moving
to the right well uh
the
uh
instead of working it out let me just
tell you what it is
the the mu
in the case of sterling numbers turns
out to be equal to
simply you start out with one over c and
you and one over c plus one
and you go up to one over
n
plus c minus one
uh so if i if set c equals two
then it says that you didn't really
shift the thing much to the right you
only shifted it by
uh you know adding n plus one
and subtracting one at the end so it
didn't didn't change by much
uh but here's an interesting thing what
if i shift by n uh
what if i consider the set of numbers n
the starting number n
uh bracket k
times n to the k now
so like n is a hundred and i'm saying
that that uh i'm starting out with 100
uh
uh sterling one and then i'm taking a
hun uh you know hundred sterling two
times a hundred
and and then the next one is you know
ten thousand
uh
and so on so i
so what does it look like there and
uh
here
here's another histogram
that corresponds to that case
so so if you if you
if you screw it you're finding out that
the
that it it's again it's always growing
up until it comes to a maximum and then
it comes down after the peak where is
the peak um
well uh
as we
uh if we look here it's going to be at
one over n plus one over n plus one
plus one over n over two n minus one
if we screw it by n
and um
uh well this is something that we can
work on um because this we can say this
is equal to one over
let's try it when n equals um
uh
five it's going to be good enough for me
to show you what
look what's happening so one-fifth plus
one-sixth plus one
seventh one-eighth one-ninth
i'm gonna write that as one plus a half
plus one third i should have taken four
instead
uh and then
i'm going to subtract
one but i'm going to take off i'm going
to call it i'm going to subtract off one
i'm going to subtract off one half which
is two fourths i'm going to subtract off
1 3 which is 2 6. i'm going to subtract
off 1 4
as 2 8.
and so
i think you can see how i got from this
line to this line
and so this is equal to 1
one half plus one third
minus
one fourth plus one fifth and
minus plus minus plus
two plus one nine this is
as everyone knows approximately the log
of two
i mean this this is a famous result
going
back to the 17th century of of the
formula for the log of two
approaching pretty rapidly uh bracketing
the value of log of two
and
therefore
the
the mean i forgot by the way that i have
to multiply it by
uh
i'm i really meant
multiply this by n
didn't i no i didn't
no
i'm sorry
i've got them all applied here uh
uh
uc is c times this
i forgot the factor of c in that formula
and so so here's my formula i have an n
on there so so what i've got is what
i've now shown is
that when you when you um
take the sterling numbers um and and you
weight them by
n to the
um
okay uh then the mean shifts way over
until the point where it comes out to be
a
log of 2 which is 0.693
times n uh is is where it occurred all
right
now um
the
the but it's it gets it gets uh
there's much more come so next thing
let's take f of f of z to be any
um
any is is some polynomial a zero a one z
up to a and z to the n
um
where let's say that uh all coefficients
are greater than or equal zero
and i'll say that
a n is greater than zero
and i'll say that f has
n
real roots
so all so all of it
this polynomial has no complex roots uh
you know all of its roots are are real
then
uh
the theorem applies that a a zero
um
less than
to a
uh
mu
um and a a ceiling of mu
greater than up to a sub n
um
and here i don't know and mu is equal to
f prime of one divided by f of one
and so what i have to show is
just that
if f has n real roots i i can reduce it
to the coin tossing problem that we had
a minute ago
well uh i just have to observe that none
of these roots can be
uh
positive
the only roots it can have are zero or
negative
uh
you see
let's let's suppose that a n is equal to
one i i can normalize saying suppose a n
equals one then we'd have f of z is
equal to z
uh
minus r1 z minus r2 uh
we just factor it into its roots
and i want to say that none of these
roots can be positive
um well you see f of a n is one uh if if
z
is uh i
i guess i could use the x instead of z
but you know we start out at zero and we
can and the value f of zero is one and
and as and as x gets bigger than zero f
of x gets bigger than one
uh so it's never going to equal zero
so so it couldn't possibly have a
positive root
uh so all of these guys are zero or
negative all these r's are negative and
so in other words uh we can always
write this
as if it were um
uh
you know z
q
okay so f of z over f of one
is equal to z minus r one over
z over one minus r one
uh and so on
z minus r n over one minus r and
remember the r's are negative
uh
and so this
this
is just
q one plus p one z
for some choices of these q's and p's
uh so
the same uh
you know dividing by f of one converts
it into the coin tossing problem that we
had before
so here's the
so here's a nice result of
is we don't have to know anything about
the coins that we're tossing we just
have to know that we're that we have
some some polynomial given to us
uh
that has that has all real roots
and all of a sudden we can solve
problems about polynomials uh because
we started out thinking about
probability theory
but so so so now
in other words you don't have to have a
probability problem in order to
find probability theory abuse to you and
the other and and so uh
in fact there's there's other kind of
sterling numbers uh sterling no
the sterling um
uh
the sterling numbers with the curly
brackets instead of
instead of
of straight brackets and this represents
the number of ways to partition a set of
n elements into m subset
now these these numbers uh the stereo
numbers have have the world's record as
being
having the most people discover them
because they arose in a different
problem
and uh
and through the ages they would
um you know in fact um
earlier this year i got a letter from a
harvard physicist uh saying he's run
into an interesting sequence have i ever
seen it before and
sure enough he had discovered these
sterling numbers
uh uh and uh in yet a different way and
it was he was looking at some finemen
diagrams and some interaction
and
uh
and so i also told him that now on the
web you can just take any any triangle
sequence that you want like you you know
so so here's the you know
book concrete math has
has sterling triangle for subsets here
for example and
uh
you can take this and you can key in uh
you can leave out the zeros if you want
so you type in one one one one three one
one seven six one two
to the encyclopedia of integer sequences
online lookup feature and it'll say
these are the sterling numbers
uh
and it's
it's also represents uh uh you know the
uh
subsets are
how many ways to partition the set into
subsets and it also will give you other
interpretations and give you references
to the literature and
and so so now you know we can compute
our way into the mathematical literature
using the using using the internet um
and uh
for cycles uh you also have the same
same kind of thing now um
what about these numbers well
if i could show that these polynomials
also have only real roots
all right so so here my polynomials are
different uh
i can't factor them in any obvious way
so here i have like x
cubed plus 3x squared plus x plus x for
for n equals 3
uh f3 f3 of x and f4 of x is
uh the next case which is x to the
fourth plus 6 x
cubed plus
7 x squared plus
x
and
so on
i would like to show that these
polynomials have
only all real roots they certainly have
non-negative coefficients and you know
leading coefficient is one
um
and uh
uh in this case the the uh
the sterling numbers satisfy a
easy recurrence of based on the
interpretation of our subs about
partitions and f n plus 1 of x
turns out to equal x times f n of x
plus f n prime of x
now i'm going to show you that
this
recurrence it means that all the roots
of these
of these polynomials are real
and that the proof is is real slick
and it's it goes like this suppose g n
of x is equal to
e to the x
times f n of x
now i've assumed i'm going to assume you
know by induction that fn of x has
n
real roots
um
that
so if we plot
gn of x it will also have n real roots
um
uh so so okay so f f n of x is going to
be like this um
and what what's the
the dln so f n of x it has
has has n roots and they're all um
so f n of x you know it's a polynomial
um and uh when x when x goes to infinity
it's it's it's positive but then it has
roots so it goes negative at the first
root because it goes positive you know
so so like f4
had four roots so it looks like this
and f5 is going to have five roots and
it's going to come come this way
but now g is going to
so this is sort of the the f f4
of x is something like this and g4 of x
what's it going to look like well we're
multiplying by a factor e to the x
so
g of x is going to go way bigger you
know it's going to it's going to also
come like this
and then it's going to come back down
though
as x goes to minus infinity it's going
to get very close but not equal to
to zero
so so look at g prime of x g n prime of
x
is equal to
okay what happens with e to the x
times f n of x
and the next term is
e to the x f n prime of x
so g n prime of x is going to be this
and and you see
g
g 4 prime of x
is going to be the place where
this curve is flat and so here's place
here's one place here here's two
three here's
four
so it's got four real roots as well
oh wait a minute um
g and prime
one
two three
i didn't
f4
one two three four
okay
oh yeah okay so so this has four real
roots um
and um
uh so in general it has n real roots
and i multiply by x and i've got n plus
one real roots and so so i've gone now
from
uh
fn having
having n real roots to f n plus one
having a and n plus one real roots okay
because because the g n prime had this
and
and uh
and and i added this x here it's another
root equal to zero
so
this proves then that these sterling
polynomials my theory applies to the
sterling polynomials and so i can figure
out
that the sterling polynomials are going
to have a peak that
does this and where is the picture right
here
here's a picture of of the sterling
numbers
are for a hundred so if you if you take
a set of 100 elements and you want to
know how many ways there are to
partition it into m parts
um
it it gets to its largest about between
28 and 29
and uh if you if you use my general
formula for mu which says calculate f
prime of one over f of one uh it turns
out that uh
that the that the mu in that case is
equal to
uh
you can write it as this the n plus
first bell number divided by the nth
bell number minus one uh the bell number
uh is one of these numbers that has no
standard notation but it's becoming more
and more standard now to use this
squiggly thing called variant pi to
represent the bell number
uh introduced by louis conte
some years ago and this is the sum of
all of the ways to partition
uh
a set into any number of parts so so
it's the sum of all the sterling numbers
it's called the bell number and uh
the
the the mean now it turns out to be
equal to
very close to the ratio of these two
bell numbers
and all of this comes out of this uh the
idea of of flipping coins
that that we were able to make this
this statement now
that's still not all
um the first thing that people do when
they
when they're
when they see a table of numbers or
sequence of numbers typically is to form
differences so let's take for example
the sterling numbers
for
permutations on five elements
so you've got
24 permutations have one cycle and 50
have two cycles 35 have three cycles
four cycles and here's the five cycles
is the identity permutation
now
let's imagine that we got zeros written
before and after
and now we can form the differences of
things so 24 minus zero is twenty 4. 50
minus 24 is 26 35 minus 50 negative 15
minus 25
minus 9 minus 1 and we get zeros at the
end here
and uh i observed that
no matter what
role of sterling's
table you start with it's going to look
something like this you're going to have
a bunch of pluses and then a bunch of
minuses and the change from plus to
minus occurs at the point mu at the
point where
uh well natural log of n in the case of
sterling number
but let's go and take another difference
so um
26 minus 24 is 2. i hope i get this
right minus 41
minus 25 plus 15 is minus 10
minus 9 plus 25 is 16 i hope
plus 16 okay and then
uh one zero zero
okay
so here we have a situation where i've
got um
a plus and then a minus and then plus
uh do it again
uh and then you'll get the idea so i'm
not gonna do it over and over but uh i
wanted to to
to give it one more
for
uh whoops no this is 13 plus 31 here
minus 10 plus 41.
minus 16
plus 10 is for plus 26 here
8 minus 16 is minus 8 1 minus is minus 7
and here i get minus 1.
so here i got a plus and then minus a
plus and minus
so if you look at how many sign changes
i've got here
i've got no sign changes in my original
sequence i got one sign change
in the second i got two sine changes in
the third
three sign changes in the fourth any
guesses
uh it's going to be true
that
you take any polynomial
of the kind we've been talking about so
any polynomial that has non-negative
coefficients
it's not the polynomial isn't zero it's
it's its leading coefficient is is is
positive
um and all its roots are real
then uh
you look at the at the coefficients and
you take differences
and if you've taken the differences k
times you're going to have exactly k
sign changes in those differences
now just
first to intuit what this might mean in
the case of second differences
the second difference is where it is
if um
the second difference says is the
increase
bigger or less than is the increase from
a k to a ak minus one ak bigger
or less than the previous increase
and so that you're taking you're
comparing a difference to a different
and so you see what's happening here is
that um as we begin the sequence
uh it is a
concave sequence which means the second
difference is positive
which means that you know we keep on
growing faster and faster as we're
getting towards the mean
uh and then but how however after a
while it starts to taper off and then
then then in the middle it's convex
sequence the second difference gets
negative
so so um and then again is concave at
the end
and this is uh informally it's a
bell-shaped curve
and uh so the um
the result uh that i'm going to prove
next is
that
the second difference always has this
property it obviously it starts out plus
then there's then it's minus for a while
and then it's plus again
there's always two changes assigned
um and it also works three change uh
third difference will also be
so every every time you have something
that has this polynomial you know with
with all real roots and and all the
coefficients are
are non-negative uh it's gonna it's
gonna the coefficients are actually
gonna be a
bell shaped and and even more
generalized if you look at third
differences fourth differences and so on
uh now so
let's
let's let does c of f is f is this
polynomial so f is equal to a 0 plus a 1
x
a n
x to the n
c of f is going to be the number of sign
changes
um
and it um
in
in the sequence um
you know zero zero up to and then a0
and go up to a n and then zeros again
after that
so i have i consider this to be an
infinite sequence with zeros afterwards
and sign changes and i'm going to um
you just
try to explain then if so if we look at
the pattern here we've got zeros for a
while and then the first coefficient
let's say is positive
and i'll write that as greater than
meaning greater than zero
and then uh
if there's if there's one sign change
there's going to be the first
case where we have a negative
coefficient
and no so in between those two
these two might be next to each other
but but otherwise we might have a few a
few greater than or equals here
of cases where positive or zero so you
know so i might have a five and then a
you know maybe zero and three and
something but then finally i get a
negative number and then i'm going to
have some
optional negative things and then
another positive one and then some you
know some of these and then a negative
and finally i uh uh it's all zeros again
after a while
so this is a typical case which has one
two three sign changes okay
as for example
and so now uh i'm going to observe that
if f
has f if f hat if c of okay i'm going to
say that c of a plus b x times f
is less than or equal
c
f
um i'm saying a and b are positive um
so if we grow polynomial by adding
another linear factor
i want to see see how this affects the
number of sign changes
and um i'm claiming that uh
it never increases the number of sign
changes and well this is pretty easy you
can see that
a and b are positive uh
so what
what we're getting if we multiply this
we're going to take this these
coefficients and multiply them by
you know so we're going to have a times
this coefficient plus b times the
previous one so that's going to be
positive the next one is going to be
this non-negative plus this one is going
to be positive 2 if this guy exists
there will be a positive here
but these will all be this
so so this first guy will you know this
is positive this one here we're going to
have a
a problem at this point i don't know
what's going to be here i'm going to
multiply this guy by a
and and and multiply and add b times
this one but this one was negative this
one is is not negative so maybe i don't
know what the sign is so there's a
question mark right there but these guys
are definitely less than or equal if
they exist
then there's a question mark here and
then there's some greater than or equals
and then there's a question mark at
wherever every transition point uh i
don't know but then at the very end um
we have a definite sign uh at the end of
that there's going to be a there's going
to be one minus here somewhere
uh and so uh
anyway uh
no matter what you put in for the
question marks you can't have more than
three uh
sign changes in this one
so i've proved this result
the other the other thing is
c of one minus x f
is always greater than c of f
and that is if you if you take a a
polynomial and then you multiply by one
minus x which is the same as taking the
difference operation um that says you
look at the coefficient and subtract the
previous one
uh then you always increase the number
of sign chains
so
um
why is that well we start with uh
with with this plus and then
some optional
optional
and we have our first minus and then
some optional guys and then another plus
and some optional might not be there and
then minus
and now
after i multiply by 1 minus x i
certainly get positive here
um and i certainly get
negative here
because this is a negative and i've
subtracted a non-negative from it and
i'm going to get a positive here because
it's plus and this
and i'm subtracting um a negative and
i'm going to have a
a positive here as well
and at the very end um i'm i'm going to
have a a minus
that that's inherited from the fact that
one of these guys was positive and then
after that i'm getting a minus so i've
got
so i had four changes here one i'm sorry
three changes here and i've got four
changes here
so i
this is a proof that
taking the difference always increases
the number of sign changes at least by
one
now uh
uh so
you start out with the constant function
and then you
and then you uh
multiply by linear factors and you and
and you say that um
uh oh i'm sorry no i
i
i'm sorry i start out with with the
function
that's from my polynomial and then i
take
differences ten times
uh then i have increased the number of
sign changes by
uh
by at least ten
um
on the uh and but on the other hand the
number of
sign changes of the polynomial 1 minus x
to the m
is exactly m
and so that proves
the result that i was
that i was claiming yeah
greater than equal
no i it has to be strictly greater so
every time i take a difference it's
going to be it's going to be one more
and and uh
let me show you the argument again so i
had a positive guy here and then i had a
negative guy here
and i had some
these guys don't necessarily have to be
present but they might be zero they
might be positive um but after i've
taken the difference i still have a
positive guy here i still have a
negative guy here still have a positive
guy the first appearance is always there
but furthermore one of these guys was
was
i mean
after i go out far enough the first
thing you hit from the right is negative
and so after i'm
after i get
there's all zeros after a point
so so so
your argument would be correct if this
was an infinite sequence
uh and yeah you know never approaching
zero but actually we do get to a point
where we actually hit zero and so then
zero minus
this negative guy is going to be
positive and so that's where that's
where
it it kicks in yeah i'm glad you asked
the question but that's the so so this
argument proves then that uh that we
have exactly this number thing okay now
um
now that was my first of two examples of
why i said hooray for probability theory
this year so now just before i leave
that one let me point out again that
what we what we were able to show then
is that a great number of combinatorial
sequences
that uh uh
can be expressed as the coefficients of
polynomials and and
you can show that
those polynomials have only real roots
and
and usually they have only non-negative
coefficients because you have some
interpretation to those non-negative
coefficients it's the running time of a
computer program or something like that
so whenever you can do that
uh and you can also prove that the
polynomial has only real roots then we
know lots about those coefficients we
know that they're bell shaped and we
know that
you know that we that
we can locate the place where the
maximum occurs and and do some things
like this with completely elementary
methods
uh
instead and and there have been long
papers trying to analyze where's the
largest sterling number of the second
time you know the
uh
and
and uh this has uh
and you can get into really complicated
formulas but now just by using this this
theorem uh uh it happened now i should i
should give credit to to uh you know the
sources of this
so uh the fir the the
first theorem that i mentioned which was
about the uh you know it gets bigger and
bigger until you get to the mean and
then
that goes back to um
a
man named rossly hefting
let me find the reference here
in
um let's see 55 yeah um 62.
okay so this was 1956.
um you know that was when i was you know
entering college i should have my
teacher should have told me about this
theorem then
um
then um
to apply to
to go the next step uh
uh to
to show that uh is bell-shaped
was taken by
a man named john doc
australia in 1964
and
this this
these theories about
um
sign changes in sequences
uh actually go way back to laguerre
um
in 1883
and uh
a
50-page paper he wrote in 1883 and then
george puglia
and gabriel sago
had a section of their of their
wonderful book problems and theorems of
analysis based on lager's
uh work
and then putting all these pieces
together
and showing how it applies to sterling
numbers
and um
uh how useful it is and and how it
solves problems that combinatorialists
have been beating their heads over for
in hard way for for a long time and many
more this was jim pittman in 1997.
and then my friend herb wolf wrote me a
letter in june which explained it to me
but these are so good these things go
back and um
so it's conceivable that
uh everybody that a lot of people in the
audience already knew about these
because because the results are old but
you know i they're they're they're
elementary uh
and uh
and uh useful in lots of lots of ways
okay
now let me yeah
by the way there's a microphone in front
of each seat in front of each
um
hello yeah uh just about the attribution
uh i think the such sequences are known
to be lock concave and uh
newton uh also did some work on that to
show that these sequences are a lot
concave so not not only are they uh
concave is the
slightly more yeah so i think it just
goes slightly perhaps i'm wrong but um
i think wilf's book generating
functionology has a chapter on exactly
this topic
and um
they're actually yeah oh okay well
that's great uh if you can give me uh of
course i have the book generate donating
functionality
but i didn't realize that that herb had
done that okay so all right uh that's uh
that's good to know
uh but i didn't know about that is
newton's connection also mentioned in
in herb's book
well maybe not but okay
yeah
well i hope you can stick around for a
little longer thank you so and give and
give you the information okay now the
other problem uh i don't have much time
to go into but i have to tell you the uh
the highlights
you can find it um
on the web in the
in in the
the preview that i have of section of
seven two five one of the art of
computer programming which is
where i'm studying uh
the problem of generating all partitions
and um in that section i decided i
wanted to
to give an exposition of the of of the
saddle point method for asymptotic
um
formulas uh
there's a
one one of the most powerful methods for
finding asymptotic
values of things
is um
uh is this
the thing from complex variable theory
called the saddle point method and uh
most of the time when when you see a
paper
that uses it it means that you're that
you have to slog through 20 pages of
of really
hairy and ugly uh formulas and estimates
of in order to finally prove a nice
result about the asymptotics and um
uh i uh
and also the books that
you know there'll be surveys about
asymptotics and then they'll have if
it's a book it'll have a chapter saying
you know introduction to the saddle
point method and saying
uh you know get ready for a hard uh for
a hard uh uh subject um and
um
and
i only know of one fairly inter
elementary introduction to the saddle
point method uh
by a professor uh who's named wang in in
hong kong but
but uh
against uh i never had seen a very good
introduction to it but but i had found
that many many cases i needed the saddle
point method and um uh i i was hoping
that i would someday be able to write an
introduction to it that that was the one
that i wish that i had that i that i had
gotten
and so now uh uh it looked like here was
my opportunity because the uh the
asymptotic value of these bell numbers
that i was talking talking to you about
this is this variant pi sub n uh is
extremely interesting uh
it grows
you know slower than factorials but
faster than it is super exponentially
it's a very interesting
asymptotic growth and
saddle point method gives a very nice a
very beautiful
way to understand exactly how fast these
numbers grow
so so this was my opportunity to write
part of my book that talks about that
gives an introduction to the saddle
point method and i had
two or three pages where the formulas
were all nice and clean and uh also
also i could i could introduce in those
same pages uh the saddle point method on
a simpler problem as well which was
training wheels where we already knew
the asymptotic value but you know we'd
sort of say
derives the asymptotic value of two to
the n uh uh by using the saddle point
method and uh
and so on now
but then the next thing was uh
to get the asymptotic value of these
sterling numbers uh you know not only to
say where does it where do these
sterling numbers peak but uh uh how fast
do they peak and and what if you're not
at the peak uh how big are the numbers
um and
for this uh there were several papers
a dozen papers in the literature
analyzing the asymptotics of this of
these sterling numbers but they were all
uh
based on long hairy uh analytic
derivations that were
that were not pleasant uh to to put it
you know and it would take a long part
of my book and i and so
uh
normally i would just say well see such
and such a paper and this this gives you
the forms but even if you look at that
paper the formulas are
are
are horrible and ugly and hard to apply
so uh i thought
so so i had a i i had a piece of luck
and i and i found a simplification as i
was looking at the saddle point method
uh where i would be able to get
formulas asymptotic formulas for the
sterling number that were
not only
simpler than the ones i found in the
literature but also more powerful the
the the uh
the the browns the uh on the error were
were sharper um
uh but i still needed to prove a certain
lemma in order to in order to make this
true and i tried and i and i and i
worked for two weeks uh
night and day uh and i couldn't find any
counter examples to the dilemma and
you know so i
i sort of knew that had to be true but i
but finally after two weeks i i decided
i had to give up on it i had already put
too much time into this and so i
couldn't and couldn't afford i had to
get you know life had to go on um i will
now tell you what what
what what the what the limit i needed
and then i'm going to show you how
probability theory uh
cracked the problem uh so uh quick
quickly then i starting out with uh
the saddle point method uh and the
and the formula for n
brace and
um
there's a closed formula that can be
written this way n factorial m factorial
times the coefficient of z to the n in
e to the z minus one to the nth power
and this is a very well known formula
and and we get this by
integrating
uh
so to get this coefficient now we have
to go into complex variable theory and
that's one over two pi i
times the an integral of g of
z to the n plus one
d z
where g of z
is
is the following formula
um
uh
i believe it's um
log of
e to the z minus 1
over alpha
minus
minus log of z
i think this is it and where alpha is
equal to
n plus one over m
um
and uh
uh
yeah because i got an f in the
denominator
okay so now uh i want to integrate some
some function then
around the in in the complex plane
and the um the key to this in the saddle
point method is to find a place where
where the derivative is zero
so so g prime and we call this a saddle
and that's a complex number sigma
and so g prime of zero of sigma is
supposed to be zero well g prime of z
is equal to
e to the z
over
alpha e to the z minus one
minus one over z
right
so that we can do and then um
so now if i set this equal to zero
it turns out that the saddle point sigma
is a root of
um
and uh now
uh
let's see
there's a whole bunch of beautiful
formulas that i instead of writing out i
will just show you from the book uh if i
can just find a page
page 40
no page 34
ah
yes
page 35 no
aha page 34 is sitting right here
so
i want to find
i want to solve this equation sigma over
1 minus e to the minus sigma equals
alpha and
a huge number of problems in
applications
dealing with epidemics and
random graphs and
all kinds of other things
are are using
formulas like this
and
if you take the function x e to the
minus x
uh you see it starts out at zero and
then as when x equals one it's equal to
uh one over e
and then it then it starts to to
decrease again
um and and
and it goes back and stays positive
and there are two values alpha oh sorry
i call this beta and alpha
that
that have the same value alpha e to the
minus alpha
equals beta e to the minus beta
where alpha is bigger than one
as it is in in in
this bar and beta is is less than one
and um it turns out that if in this case
sigma is also equal to alpha minus beta
so the the saddle point that i need for
studying sterling numbers
is is given in terms of the two roots to
this uh like you know
alpha e to the minus alpha equals beta e
to the minus beta uh
uh a uh
and as they say this uh arises in an
amazing number of
of problems and one one such uh pair of
values is take alpha equals log of four
and beta equals log of two
then you can check uh
log of four divided by
e to the log of four is log of four over
four
and you log of two over
i mean over
two these are equal you see so
you have a
typical example of of two numbers that
that satisfy this and in fact there's a
general uh
uh if if you take sigma to to be the the
parameter instead of alpha and b instead
of alpha you can write alpha equals
sigma
e to the sigma over e to the sigma minus
one and beta equals sigma
over e to the sigma minus one for any
value of sigma from zero to infinity
gives you a solution alpha and beta to
the n and conversely
um
now
what i found was that i could
if i if i continued in taking more
derivatives so
so i found g double prime of z t triple
prime of z these are the the the values
of these derivatives is what you need
uh to figure out how the function is
behaving uh around the saddle point uh
when you plug in z equals um
equals sigma because of taylor's theorem
so
can you read this formula
um
g of sigma plus i t
so uh
at the saddle point plus a little
up up and down in the imaginary axis uh
we can expand it uh and uh you see the
higher order terms the higher order
powers of t are involving the kth
derivative of
of g at
sigma
and
the
the thing that i noticed was that g of
sigma
what okay so you can you can
calculate these derivatives and uh you
can express them in many different ways
but the but there was a there was one
way was particularly
simple
and uh let's see it's in the answer page
here
70. yeah here we go so
g n
plus one of z
um
over n factorial
uh is equal to minus one to the n
times
well
let me put the sigma in there instead g
n plus one of sigma
over n factorial
which is what i need
uh is is minus one to the n
and um um
over sigma to the n plus one
uh
and then it's like one
minus
the summation on k of
n
bracket k alpha k beta to the n minus k
um
these are
the
this is the other big triangle after the
binomial coefficients from the sterling
numbers the next important triangle is
the eulerian numbers
and what what and eulerian numbers occur
and these are the number of permutations
on n elements that have k
uh
what they called
descents it means that that that it goes
down
as you go from one one place to another
so
um
these
for example the eulerian numbers
for n equals three are one four one
and n equals four it's one eleven eleven
1.
people keep discovering these numbers
again a lot
uh this says if you have
if you have uh
if you look at the
at the permutations and three elements
one of them has two descents it's three
two one it goes down twice uh four of
them uh have just one descent and the
case where there's no descents is the is
one two three and similarly with
with four elements you you have a
certain chance of having one descent two
descents
or or three decent
now uh
these these numbers um
uh
anyway
occurred in this formula
and i had to prove that this quantity
is small
divided by c
so
if i could prove that
that and alpha and beta are this
complicated is this are the strange
function of sigma that i wrote down you
know it's alpha
alpha is is is is this and beta is it
and as sigma
uh
goes from zero to infinity i it was i
was convinced that these that that this
particular combination
of
alpha and beta was what was monotone it
was monotonic and it and went from one
to zero
uh so that
then i would have a beautiful bound for
this because this this quantity that i
needed to bound was always between zero
and one
now in these other book papers that i
found in the literature
the
authors had gone through long
calculations with all kind of hairy
analysis in order to prove not that this
was
between zero and one but that this
didn't grow too fast
you know um and so i and and so here you
know i i thought you know the sterling
numbers are one of the key things in
mathematics we've got to have we've got
something if someday
you know
god wouldn't have wanted there to be no
nice proof of their asymptotics and
there must be some
you know
some way that that makes it come out
clean
and uh all i needed then was to prove
that this that this function is actually
uh i know
monotonic well i wasn't able to prove my
monotonic but i was able to prove that
it's between zero and one
and um
and the the uh
and it would use probability theory and
that's my final punchline today but i'll
show you how it works
so there's a beautiful result that
somebody
named um
tani discovered
in 1973
and that and said that the probability
that uh
if if you um
take
random numbers between zero and one
uh so we call them uniformly random
numbers between zero and one u1 up to u
n
and and so these are
between you know
uh
real numbers not integers between zero
and one and
and you consider
the probability that the floor
of u1 plus un
is equal to k
that this is actually exactly this
eulerian number n choose k over n
factorial
so
you see what i mean i'm taking random
draws of n identical numbers and then i
add them all up and what's the integer
part of that number
and it's the same as the number of
permutations the center of the
probability that a permutation has that
many descents
and the proof is very easy
because you can
imagine that i
said v1 equal u1 v2 equals u1 plus u2
modulo 1.
throw away the integer part v3 is
same thing
of
mod 1.
these numbers v1 v2 v3 are also
uniformly distributed and independent of
each other
and the number of times you d you
descended is the number of times that v1
is is the number of times i mean the
number of times you had to actually drop
down
by taking mod 1 is the number of times
the v's actually have descents
and so if you're looking at
so so if
you if you look at at all
in in in space that all the cases of uh
and you identify um
the v's by
by by the
the permutation that each
the the the volume of a set and n space
in which any particular permutation
occurs is equal to one over n factorial
uh so the
the uh chance that there are
are a certain number of descents is
exactly the number of times that uh you
uh
that you know if v1 is greater than v2
then
then we've increased the four by one so
this is the proof this is tani's
proof that gives you a
connection between these eulerian
numbers and
probability theory
now this mean
okay i want to evaluate alpha to the k
beta the n minus k what is that it's the
sum of these eulerian numbers times
alpha to the k beta to the k our formula
for alpha
was sigma
to the k e to the k sigma
over e to the sigma minus 1 to the k and
beta to the n minus k
is sigma
to the n minus k
over e to the sigma minus 1 to the n
minus k so this is equal to so so a lot
of things cancel here and this turns out
to be summation n choose n euler
eulerian k e to the k
times the saddle point times this
constant factor sinks sigma to the n
over
e sigma minus one to the n this
this thing here to the end so i need to
uh
bound this this quantity and but but you
see what what i can do is this
i if i if i take if i have any function
and i can consider f of x one plus
f of uh i i want to know the integral of
f of
the floor of x1 plus xn
d dx1
n and i integrate over
over the n dimensional cube 0 to 1.
this is equal to the sum
this is equal to f of 0
times the probability that that the
floor is is equal to zero plus f of one
plus
times the probability that the floor of
of these guys is equal to one
and so on
now
because it can only
integrating these real
real values over this quantity so it's
equal to in other words it's the sum of
f of n
times n
sorry f of k times n k
over n factorial
uh
that's the formula that i needed in in
my in in my uh proof so
all i had to do was write this
this strange quantity as an integral and
and i can write this as the integral
from 0 to 1
of
of dx1 through dxn
e to the
floor of
x1
plus xn times
sigma
uh this way
uh
by
by the uh
by the formula i just gave so so this uh
this integral equals that sum
and uh uh well this happens to be less
than or equal to
the same integral without the floor
and this is and this is just the
integral of e to the x
sigma from zero to one take an n time
which is
which is e to the sigma over
i or something like this i i can't
remember but it is you know just
exactly the factor that i needed
to give the upper bound and similarly
the lower bound it's it's greater than
or equal to the same thing with that but
i subtract one
um
and and again uh you gave exactly the
lower bond i needed for the asymptotics
so
so here was a case then that no that no
that i i i'm working an algebraic
problem
i came i come up with um these eulerian
numbers
um
then uh
lo and behold that i once learned that
there's a way to relate ordinary numbers
to the probability that permutations
have a certain
uh
number of descents therefore
uh i i i i can write as an integral uh
uh so it's also the probability that
uniform random numbers have a certain
floor and therefore i can write it as an
integral and and that leads to the
the bound so the the the
the end of the story then is
is just that now there is a
a formula for
early numbers
which is
which is a completely uniform
i've got the formula
on page 35 so all i have to do is
display it for you and then we can click
uh there's got to be a page 35 in my
right here 35 so so
the final formula
for sterling numbers then is this is
this formula here whoops um
you got to turn you yeah i'm sorry to
make it hard on you
uh
this is the the the leading term is
actually easy to evaluate once you
understand alpha and beta and then these
other uh
these other terms the the main point is
that now the b's are known to be
well behaved and
and uh this works over the entire range
of of uh
from m equals one to m equals n
and uh it says here uh in
that formula 43 looks a bit scary
because it's designed to apply over the
whole entire range but significant
simplifications are possible when it
when when m is small or large and those
are also not not not hard to work out
but i had to end with something a little
scary because it's
halloween tomorrow
okay
sorry that i that i didn't make it as
easy as i thought it was going to be but
i think at least you can see why i was
in love with probability theory twice
this year
thanks
the electric field right here increases
really dramatically because